en el último foro económico mundial
presencial en enero del 2020 el mundo
era un lugar muy diferente donald trump
era presidente de los eeuu y un orador
principal el commit 19 aún no había
sacudido la economía mundial y la
adormecida ciudad de la estación de
esquí se convirtió como cada año en una
que alberga personajes reconocidos
mundialmente durante su época invernal
desde el príncipe carlos de inglaterra
hasta grietas de amber pasando por los
principales ejecutivos del mundo
vinieron a hablar a ver y ser vistos
este año davos tiene un telón de fondo
diferente en primer lugar es primavera
la variante omicron ha hecho que la
cumbre se retrase y no coincida con el
invierno como de costumbre la edición de
este año se titula la historia en un
punto de inflexión mientras la economía
mundial sigue lidiando con el cambio
climático pero también con el aumento de
la inflación las consecuencias del cobi
19 y la guerra en ucrania en el foro
virtual del año pasado vladimir putin
fue uno de los principales oradores este
año la delegación rusa no ha sido
invitada software
aquí estamos en una antigua casa rusa
donde rusia siempre se presentaba en
davos que va a ser una exposición de los
crímenes que rusia está cometiendo en
ucrania en este mismo momento house en
este año volodymyr selenski que también
ha participado anteriormente realizará
su intervención por videoconferencia más
de 50 autoridades gubernamentales unirán
a unos 2.500 delegados discutirán una
amplia gama de temas desde el aumento de
los precios de la energía hasta la
pobreza y el metaverso desde su primera
edición en 1971 los organizadores y los
participantes dicen que el foro sigue
siendo una reunión con ideas
consecuentes pero los críticos dicen que
es un festival elitista impregnado de
hipocresía citando a multimillonarios
que vuelan en aviones privados para
hacer promesas grandiosas para combatir
el calentamiento global